vad was revered as a hero among his own
people he was absolutely viewed as a
terrible bloodthirsty villain by his
enemies Vlad is born here in sigara in
1431 his father is a member of the order
of dragons the dracul hence vlad's
childhood nickname Dracula son of the
dragon as he turns into the monster he
becomes he gains another chilling name
Vlad Dracula the Impaler
this is the room where Dracula was born
how amazing is that and this one
painting tells us why people thought vad
the Impaler was Dracula just look at
this image his victims are being impaled
while these people are still
alive it's bloody it's gory it's
shocking and he's having a meal while
that is going on